[Music]
you're in the jobs movie and you play
Wozniak the was yes was who of course
co-created Apple yeah I mean Steve Jobs
he was one of the co-founders he created
the Apple one motherboard and Steve Jobs
odd and was like this this could make us
a fortune and and the two of them went
off and created this legacy and and it's
incredible and daunting to play a living
breathing person who's very much still
in the zeitgeist and you guys actually
got to go and I don't know if you shop
there if you actually just or just saw
did you shoot in the actual garage shot
in the garage in the garage where they
invented the computer it was one of the
most surreal experiences my life there
was one day where one of the set
registers came down with this large bag
filled with these things and I said
what's in there and he goes there
Steve's childhood journals I'm not sure
what I should do with them and so you
should probably donate them to the
Smithsonian or put them back where you
found them you know like it was but it
was trapped in time that's so amazing
you got to shoot there we have a clip
here from jobs I think this is when you
guys you the woz and and and the jobs
are in the car yes trying to think of
the name that they're going to give
that's right is this right this is right
and I think the rest of different jobs
what about enterprise computers no no
Star Trek device I swear I will drive
this car right on you run the car right
off the Jesus calm down seriously okay
nothing tracking Jesus feel like
something that people will relate to you
know I'm like needs to be something that
you seen you're just like man I just got
to have it
Apple
excuse me
now Apple like a fruit with the fruit of
creation Apple it's a simple but
sophisticated for its hiring the
phonebook 50 fastest that is so much
better than phaser being computers you
know you mentioned to us that just
before the show you said that you were
so excited to be here because this stage
is where they shot one of your favorite
movies which one is the Goonies is with
my all-time faves was I I I watched your
show one day and I saw Johnny Galecki on
and and he was reliving his childhood
experience of watching The Goonies here
and and portraying the character of
chunk did he asked us when Johnny
Galecki was here he so many actors of
your generation and performers are
obsessed with The Goonies and Johnny
Galecki came here and said okay I want
he wanted to be chunk yeah and he wanted
me to be sloth yeah and we recreated it
here and you saw that iy I saw it and I
was very angry and jealous and so I I
kind of decided today if it's okay with
you that I would like to live my dream
version of The Goonies with you if
that's what you want to recreate okay so
you want to recreate the scene do you
want to recreate the same see you know I
feel like that's been done to death that
one time so I would rather do something
a little different okay you're gonna
play the character of sloth why am I
always slot because we have that draft
thing going on I'm gonna play mama
fratelli and I and I brought a couple of
props I hope you don't mind okay and
this is the scene and that you could put
this for me here okay this is the scene
towards the end of the movie this is for
you towards the end of the movie I don't
want to give anything away but it says
The Goonies it's been around for 70
years
well yeah you'll see what happens but
it's very touching it's the dramatic
kind of apex of the film okay ladies and
gentlemen enjoy this quick recreate on
the set where the Goonies was shot here
of the ending of The Goonies let's take
a look right now
[Applause]
[Music]
come to me baby come on whoa you burger
Oh that's love baby I may have been bad
a man kept you chained to that room but
it was don't you remember when I used to
sing to you when you were little
rock-a-bye baby on the treetop when the
wind blows the cradle will rock when the
bough breaks the cradle will fall
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]